Facebook will hold a company-wide
meeting today so employees can ask
questions about the unfolding scandal
with a political data firm Cambridge
analytic huh
now this comes after news that the firm
gained access to data for more than 50
million Facebook users which it used to
target ads in the 2016 election that
news sent Facebook stock tumbling 7%
yesterday and that is a biggest drop in
four years
Cambridge analytic a deny drung doing it
said in a statement that it deleted all
the Facebook data and derivatives in
cooperation with Facebook facebook says
it is quote in the process of conducting
a comprehensive internal and external
review as we work to determine the
accuracy of the claims that the Facebook
data in question still exists CBS News
contributor Nicholas Thompson is editor
in chief of Wired and is going to help
us untangle all of these wires Nick help
me understand exactly what Cambridge
analytic is alleged to have done wrong
and where that departs from the fact
that previous campaigns other companies
use this Facebook data where what line
was crossed here so the line that's
crossed is this and researcher works for
a company called GSR call him dr. K dr.
K sets up an app he collects a bunch of
user data from Facebook that he was
supposed to keep himself that's the
agreement he signed with Facebook
instead he sells that all the camera
Jena lytic Oh keep it himself for the
purposes of what we're running an app
like if the point of Facebook is you
give people data they build apps on top
of it if they have data they can build
better apps but they're not supposed to
take everything they gather and they're
not supposed to give it to other people
so the story breaks in 2015 that all
this data has gone to Cambridge
analytical and it's gone for political
targeting at that point Facebook should
have made absolutely certain that it had
all been deleted so now what we're
learning is the story is coming back and
seems like the data wasn't deleted and
we have a whistleblower explaining
exactly how it was used the hits keep
coming it seems to me for facebook they
this is yet another one where did they
put a foot wrong did they not in 2015 do
what they were supposed to do you can
argue they put a foot wrong when they
out app developers to collect data from
users friends would they closed that
door in 2014 shortly after this app was
launched it was grandfathered into the
old open policies that's how they're
able to collect so much data so you can
blame Facebook for the original policies
you can blame Facebook for not cracking
down harder when they first learned
about it and you can blame Facebook for
having a very flat-footed response when
this nightmare story broke a couple of
days ago now Cambridge analytic has
worked for the Trump campaign but they
said they never used to you that
information that they that they obtained
from Facebook do you believe that no I
mean it's hard to believe anything
Cambridge analytic assess after watching
the undercover documentary where they
talk about manipulating people with
Ukrainian girls I mean this is a company
that does not appear to have truth as
one of its top priorities so they've
said that they deleted the data however
people have told reporters including a
wired insiders who have had access to
their computers that the data was not
deleted so so how do we know how they
use that data what they do with it well
what they did is they created profiles
of users psychological profiles of users
and then helped political campaigns
around the world target ads based on
those users so if it knows what kind of
person you are
Cambridge analytic acclaims they can
show you ads or information that will
affect your views of politics now
there's an interesting argument saying
that that is all baloney and you can't
do that but does it matter that's what
Cambridge analytic us sold so let's go
back to Facebook's responsibility and
all of this Facebook found out about
this breach two years ago since then
Mark Zuckerberg has been on this great
American road trip cheryline Berg has
Sheryl Sandberg has been promoting her
lean in movement we know from an article
that they were obsessed with polling
their own reputations at one point and
by the way you can have side jobs and do
all of that and multitask but at what
point does management have bare
responsibility here who was manning the
ship so this all comes to a light in
December 2015 and then Facebook gets a
bunch of promises that the data has been
deleted and then as far as I can tell
after they get those promises from
Cambridge analytic and from the
researchers there they completely forget
about the story it goes off their rape
well they have all hands on deck
company-wide meeting today what do you
think needs to happen I think a lot of
people are gonna say why have you not
come out in spoken why have we not heard
anything yet from Mark Zuckerberg or
from Sheryl Sandberg
has very deftly avoided all criticism
during the last three months of chaotic
nightmares in baseball they've had some
great PR but a lot of questions from
lawmakers both in the US and the UK
directed specifically towards them and
market sector I mean rapidfire every
hour thank you thank you